what's the few tubes welcome back to my
channel Richard on data my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about data so it's almost the new
year which means people are starting to
make their resolutions so you've got
your quitting smoking getting out of
debt losing weight eating healthy all
that good stuff but there's tons of
people out there who are thinking about
making big career moves in this year as
well so for those of you out there who
are thinking about data science I
thought what better of a time to
actually share my story and how I got
into data science myself maybe it
resonates with some of you out there
maybe it's something you keep in the
back of your mind as you head into 2020
hopefully we'll see before I actually
get into my story
all I ask of you guys is to smash the
like button hit the subscribe button if
you haven't done so in the past then hit
the notification bell see you never miss
an updates new videos from Richard on
data every week so back in the day when
I was growing up I had always heard you
should figure out what you want to do
with your life as early as possible that
way you can start early and you get a
head start on it and you'll get good at
it and I definitely think there's a
giant element of truth to that here's
the problem though and I think a lot of
people fall into this boat I had no idea
what I wanted to do something that I
always knew that I was good at was
talking to people and building
relationships with people but I didn't
know how to monetize that so a little
bit on the whole communicating with
people talking to people a little bit
later in the story but here's the thing
I've always loved money and I have no
shame in admitting that Benjamin
Franklin you're a good friend of mine
you never let me down I always have
enjoyed teaching but the problem in
society today is that teachers are
seriously underpaid so I didn't want to
do that but I didn't want to chase money
the entire way or I would have just gone
into medicine and I honestly can't
handle the stress and strain of medicine
now when I was growing up I did discover
pretty early on that I was really good
at math so I never actually did
sticks or anything like that in high
school but your standard algebra algebra
to pre calc calculus I was really good
at all of it and these are really
subjects that a lot of people out there
they kind of struggle with so it got me
thinking if I'm talented at this maybe
that's something that I can uniquely
monetize on so when I started my first
year at college I tentatively decided on
stats as my major and I wanted to do
stats rather than pure mathematics
because it seemed easier at least
naively to apply to various industries
than pure mathematics would be keep in
mind I had no interest whatsoever in
being a college professor in doing
research in developing the field I just
want to work on cool problems using some
kind of quantitative skillset and I took
my first intro stats class in college it
was alright I don't have really any
strong opinions about it one way or the
other I wasn't super passionate about it
I didn't dislike it either it was just
an okay class I figured with that class
that I was just beginning to scratch the
surface so in my next year of college I
signed up for this 400 level theoretical
statistics class and whoo it was a
disaster this was actually the only
class that I've ever straight-up failed
in my entire life now I do have my
criticisms about how the class was run
the material general stuff like that but
at the end of the day I myself do take
full ownership for failing that class
and I realized it was because of my own
failure to plan and my inability to get
excited and to see the bigger picture
you see theoretical statistics can be a
pretty abstract topic I don't dislike it
I don't like to bag on it I think it's
important in the grander scheme of
things but if you don't have something
to really be excited about and you're
jumping headfirst into theoretical
statistics you don't necessarily know
what you're getting yourself into you
could be setting yourself up for some
problems if you do that now right around
that
I actually ended up changing
universities and the reason for that is
a different story for a different day
but the long and the short of it was I
was going into an entirely different
program an entirely different curriculum
different everything so I took a class
in intro probability no big deal it was
fine whatever but then a year after that
I actually took a class in data mining
so it started getting into linear models
machine learning clustering
classification that kind of stuff and
that absolutely blew my mind so honestly
after that the rest of school was great
I took some more classes and applied
statistical principles some statistical
computing more linear models more
machine learning that kind of stuff and
accidently I'd really stumbled into
something that I'd actually liked I had
gone into the major completely blindly
not knowing anything about it not
knowing what data mining was what
machine learning was what linear models
were none of that I knew nothing about
it but going through school it became
clear to me statistics can be applied to
so many different domains
I saw the applications of it automotive
healthcare insurance
Pharma whatever it could be you could
apply statistics to it in some way shape
or form and it just got me enormous ly
excited about it and it convinced me I
had picked the right path then right
around that time I started to hear about
this terminology of data science and I
did a video a little while back about
what data science actually is and I
didn't understand it to that level of
granularity but I got the broader idea
that there's a tremendous amount of
power when you combine statistics with
programming and computing abilities
programming was never necessarily
something I had a super strong
background in especially before getting
into college but I learned are in my
college classes and to be honest it was
pretty intuitive and easy to me a lot of
people they do find are a little
challenging and they find it to have a
learning curve I don't know what it was
about me I found it pretty easy and
intuitive that's probably because I was
coming from a statistics background R
was the first programming language I've
ever picked up and when I learned other
programming languages down the road I
actually had more difficulty getting
into those than I did with R whereas for
most people it's the exact opposite so I
don't know who knows it is what it is
so after college I went back to grad
school because guess what in the data
science world it's the sad fact of the
matter that you are going to be better
off if you had a masters or a PhD and
again I had no interest in developing
the field doing research any of that so
I was totally content with number one
just getting the credentials that go
behind a master's but then going back
and conquering my nemesis which was the
theoretical statistics stuff which three
years ago I really sucked at so at that
point I was in a pretty good position I
got my first couple internships while I
was still in school and there were
naturally more surprises both good and
bad and I'd say the biggest surprise and
the biggest thing I learned during that
process was that I was a super
enthusiastic ignoramus what I mean is
this so this is definitely true in the
statistics world and I've heard it from
people coming from other disciplines as
well basically you come out of school
and the things which you learned in
school think of that as a hammer
now you're going out looking for a nail
to that hammer and the problem is real
world data real world datasets real
world problems which you're gonna solve
are way more complex than that model is
going to allow for problems in the real
world are often a lot more nebulous
unstructured the client doesn't even
really know what they want sometimes
these are just not necessarily problems
which you run into in your statistics or
your computer science or even your raw
data science program which you might do
in school actually when I was in school
there wasn't even a formal data science
per
that was even established yet now
remember when I said earlier in this
video that I always enjoy talking to
people communicating with them building
relationships well here's what I found
in the data science work that I've done
so literally every job every internship
and with every single individual client
engagement that I've ever had the data
science work that I have done has
operated something like a consulting
engagement that is you're working on
problems which don't have clear or
objective answers you have to talk to
your client you have to sit down with
them understand their problems try and
live in their world empathize with them
all that good stuff what ends up
happening is that guides your creative
process I keep harping on in all my
videos that data science is a super
creative field and it's the
communication with your client as well
as the understanding that you pick up of
the domain which ends up guiding your
thought process it's now happened to me
several times in my work that a client
will ask me to do something or they'll
ask me to solve some problem and then I
get all inquisitive I ask them questions
like why are we doing this what's the
purpose of this analysis what problem
are we really trying to solve just
general things like that and then I come
up with various other ideas that are a
little bit beyond the scope of what was
asked for then I'll have the
conversation with the client about
whatever this idea is maybe I'll make a
little prototype of it just little
things like that and they've come back
and they've said wow I didn't even know
that that was possible because they're
not mathematically or statistically
minded now these ideas piggyback on
various things that I've learned in my
day things in the statistics and the
computing realms but it's really moments
like that which give me the most joy
that I've ever experienced in my work
far more so even than prototyping a
really nice neural network that has
really good performance on the test set
although let's be honest that is pretty
awesome still so at the end of the day I
love data science
but I stumbled upon it by complete
accident and I found it because it's a
natural marriage of a couple different
things that I really enjoy specifically
communicating with people and statistics
and it also brought together something
that I didn't even realize at the time
that I enjoyed which was programming if
you're good at a couple of those things
yourself guess what you may not be good
at that other skill or you may not know
that you're good at it
but it's something that you can work on
Foster and really grow and at that point
you have a really strong chance of being
a successful data scientist if that's a
field that you want to get into I hope
this resonated with somebody out there
who might be thinking about data science
as a career path now again if you have a
mathy mind like me and you also like
building relationships granted you do
need both of those qualities but if you
think you have them I really do hope you
find a way to get into the field and it
brings you as much joy as it has made to
this point so far so thanks for watching
this video until next time Richard on
data